and everything that we dropping it's hot
you dig boo late cat podcast bootleg cab
show special guest in here it's been a
few years since i uh have interviewed my
friend right here yellow bz hey what's
happening the last time i saw you we
were at uh in miami at uh
i don't know drake was having some sort
of thing with future it was at a damn uh
dave and buster's and i wouldn't have
gotten in if it hadn't been for you i
just kind of attached myself to your
entourage i seen my guy say come on in
man
i can't let you sit outside yeah it was
a good time man but how's everything
been bro
yo let's talk because i feel like
i'm glad to see that like some of these
wild like accusations that were thrown
your way
have been cleared up right but i feel
like
as men in 2022
it's unfortunate that like somebody
could just lie on your name and it's on
you
to shake that you know what i'm saying
talk about what happened and just like
how you've been dealing with that [ __ ]
cause
you know the truth your team knows the
truth the [ __ ] law knows the
truth right
but once like your mug shot goes up in a
certain manner on some of these blog
sites you have like you have that
certain [ __ ] that you gotta shake
yourself right
basically [ __ ] [ __ ] just lied
i'm guessing you know
gotta be over the money [ __ ] but want
some money probably and i'm not the type
of dude who you can
you know blackmail a black ball or
whatever the [ __ ] you want to call it so
you have to go with your move
and i'm guessing um
[ __ ] she probably
oh she's coaching the mic if you can
shut your phone off all right go ahead
man oh i'm guessing like
she thinking that she won't make the
allegation uh she was gonna go
fast and all this other [ __ ] she didn't
know the police had a whole type of
different
uh swing gave me for they on purpose so
[ __ ]
it took longer than what she thought i
guess she thought i was gonna reach out
and try to come come uh drop a bag to
get it to go away yeah and i'm not that
type of [ __ ] and uh [ __ ] that's just
what it is i let the loud uh put into
the low hands [ __ ] dna came back all
that type [ __ ]
everything they just caught up in all
the [ __ ] lies she did yeah cause like
most people like you said
she probably figured if i throw this on
him people just want to pay to get it to
go away correct but i feel like if you
do that while it might be less of a
headache
it also feels like
damn maybe he did do something and if
you are real if you're innocent you're
like nah [ __ ] that let's see this [ __ ]
through cause i you ain't going to deal
with that headache which i understand
with me i don't give a [ __ ] about that
like i'm not putting you not for the
black bomb if you want to try to
say i gotta give you 10 15 20 000 or
whatever you're not saying that's what
right what she was on but you know what
i'm saying like if that's what this is
going to be baby you have to work your
move yeah because i'm different not
doing it because i'm i'm knowing like
[ __ ] that ain't me by far 100 um has it
uh negatively affected you at all in
terms of just like in a corporate world
y'all kind of you know people want to
bag up and see how the [ __ ] play out
before they just you know i'm saying
either stick with you or do some
business with you for sure right yeah
because i feel like um
like i said man it's unfortunate because
it's it's
do you always see the accusations
printed in big headlines
but when it gets cleared up it ain't as
big of a story because it ain't as juicy
that's why you got to go on your own
press runs and you have to really just
put this [ __ ] together for your own
benefit and pray because
your ass hide and drop for sure 100
percent no the the the
the room's gonna spread ten times faster
than the truth a hundred percent man uh
hey what up it's bootleg kev we gotta
stop the interview to tell you what our
good friends at my bookie football
season has started my favorite time of
the year cause i love to gamble on
football it makes watching football so
much fun it's my like literally i just
love watching football and i love it
even more when i got money on the line
and no matter where you are right now
what state what country you can get in
on the action it's a winning season go
to my bookie sign up for a new account
register and get that double deposit
bonus using the promo code bootleg now
let me tell you what that means that
means when you go to my bookie let's say
you make a 250 deposit using the promo
code bootleg you'll have 500 to gamble
with that's right they're going to
double your [ __ ] money right now they
got the prop builder you could bet on
whether or not i don't know
well matthew stafford throw for three
touchdowns will kylo murray rush for a
touchdown you could put all those on one
thing and secure the [ __ ] bag
all right get online with your boy let's
get this money together my bookie go
sign up with that promo code bootleg and
double your deposit right now go
register you just dropped a new tape on
the
recently uh
yeah the fifth
yeah badass yellow boy is that yes sir
yeah um i love the artwork i was just
talking to jid about
that style of artwork right it reminds
me of like some og cash money no limit
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying what was
the like why
what inspired that choice for the
artwork man because like i had already
been wanting to do the badass yellow boy
remake for the long just because my name
is you know that's like one of a texas
it's it they from louisiana but you know
what i'm saying you and it'll be shout
out to um you know there'll be uh rp
yellow boy you know he from louisiana
but that [ __ ] was real big in the south
and it would be yeah for people who
don't know unlv was the first group to
really pop cash money off in the 90s
yeah
they that song
was like a big ass song in the south
where i know in texas in louisiana can
we get the mic in front of you a little
bit because they're kind of far from the
right yeah and chasing louisiana for
sure and then juvenile redid the
[ __ ] he did uh set it off you
know what i'm saying so i've been want
to redo that song for the long because
it just makes sense just because i'm a
badass yellow boy type [ __ ] so when i
actually had the producer to redo the
beat we um i went and dropped that
[ __ ] and um we was trying to
come up with the album and at first we
were gonna drop an album at first but
then we were like man i ain't dropped in
a minute so let me just warm the streets
up with a mixtape first and then we're
gonna drop that album so like they were
like what you gonna name the mixtape i
like [ __ ] i just did the badass yellow
but that's just a perfect name in the
cell yeah yeah it's it's it's you got
ice cream vessel on the album shout out
to vezner who just got a great situation
over at qc um
uh who else is on the project i think it
was just him in
uh
yeah le mans uh uh one couldn't be one
of my new upcoming artists you signing
them yeah we're gonna sign some people
from dallas yeah nice
do you feel like um
yo dallas is uh obviously
you you have a lot to do with it being
as
big on the national map of hip-hop as it
is
now because i feel like when i was kind
of coming up like dallas like we didn't
there was the little will record my
dougie there was um shout out to darrow
what was the other dude who had a deal
[ __ ] i forget his name but he had a
big tuck big toe yeah that's dsl
dsl they hit him and tom tom
um we had um
the head miss puke and miss lucci i mean
we got miss spooky miss lucci um who had
like some big [ __ ] young nation had some
big [ __ ] going on they had like the
stinky leg [ __ ] going on yeah they had
what you had the stinky like yeah my
doggie they had yeah mr hit that whole
uh and uh walking around the club [ __ ]
everybody
yeah
prince rick uh
i didn't even know that was a dallas
record yeah a little running throw that
ass in the circle um
[ __ ] but i feel i was gonna say like i
feel like
for a city that is like
kind of been under represented in
hip-hop right now that y'all are on the
forefront
it always feels like there's some drama
popping off between all the artists in
dallas
yeah why do you think like is it just is
it just it is what it is
mentality
instead of like people want to shine
they want to shine on themselves right a
lot of [ __ ] just want to
attention all on them they don't know
how to they don't know it she's it's
strength in numbers yeah cause it feels
like it's like if everyone moved in
unison it would be a very like different
type of city because you think about
atlanta yeah and you know everybody's
doing records with everybody there's
[ __ ] the migos have done songs with
everybody gucci's doing songs for
everybody to change i mean go on and on
and on but there is so much young talent
um obviously rip the mode 3 you know
trap boy freddie yourself there's so
much dope talent out of dallas that um
yeah i mean i feel like
i feel the same way about jacksonville
because you see jacksonville they got a
lot of dope artists but it feels like
everybody's like trying to tear each
other down and it's like i don't know
that [ __ ] just be crazy bro i don't
[ __ ] just
i don't know it just should be envious
have you cause i feel like you're kind
of the first guy to really pop from this
new wave of dallas artists in a way that
you did like that's on me is a [ __ ]
smash record right so it's like did you
feel like when you first really were
getting those looks and really started
to get that national attention that you
started to feel the most hate from your
hometown of course like at first you
know everybody gonna look but i think
you know that's kind of like everywhere
so i always get like talk from everybody
i always say man that [ __ ] happened like
they gonna love you then they gonna hate
you then they'll probably just start
back love me again you know what i'm
saying but
i was getting a lot of love then you
know come to hate the crabs in the
barrel uh crabs in the bird [ __ ] like
people want to
just use your name for the click bait
now type of [ __ ] but
deal with the deal i appreciate y'all
watching but listen our partners at blue
chew they got you handled fellas and etc
whatever you are they got it if you got
a dick blue chew is for you because they
will make sure your dick performs at all
time levels i mean like lebron his first
three seasons with the heat type levels
i mean your wife will thank you for it
everybody will thank you for it [ __ ]
even if you just take a blue chew and
jerk your dick it's a it's a stronger
jerk i swear to god stronger [ __ ] jerk
for sure you're gonna be beating your
dick like i stole something
so what you gotta do is go to
bluetooth.com right now
use the promo code bootleg right now and
you're gonna get your first month free
and this is the great thing about
bluechew the same active ingredients as
viagra and as cialis
but you don't gotta go to the doctor's
office yeah who wants to go hang out at
the doctor's office and be like hey doc
you got some [ __ ] pills for me nobody
wants to do that no you sign up at blue
chew use the promo code bootleg and
you're getting your first month
delivered to your door
in discreet packaging i'm telling you
you're going to thank me later all right
if you've gotten bluetooth already just
dm me tell me just just dm me no photos
just tell me how you know let me just
tell you it's [ __ ] amazing our
producer cyrus's daddy 70 took the blue
chew he's [ __ ] just beating down all
the senior citizen [ __ ] available in
arizona right now so go to bluetooth.com
use that promo code bootleg or just hit
the link in the description of this
video let's get back to the interview
who are some of the artists beside your
boy moz that you're trying to sign that
you're [ __ ] with out of your city
jose bodega um
who we got yes who else we got out there
uh little mac he's gonna go crazy i know
for sure my eyes jose both day on mac
for sure we gonna we gonna [ __ ] with
them yeah
shout out to uh your guy moz what's the
name of the label uh pmg pmg yeah pmg nt
so you got you got a tattooed yeah you
got a few record labels is this just two
record labels tattooed on your arms
that's cash you got no limit cash money
ugk
wrap a lot ruthless reckless you got the
ruthless tattoo yeah i got bad boy i got
nwa you just got the rap arm
trillion t death row
uh
seeing me that's pretty [ __ ] i got bwa
uh i think i got cmg i got a lot of
[ __ ] over here
shout out to uh kevin gates yeah
you got
you and kevin gates got a close
relationship yeah that need crazy that's
mogado he's an interesting guy yeah yeah
he's intense oh my god
me and him had a great interview
recently and
you know we had that one interview that
went viral a few years ago where my
co-host dj had touched his arm oh you
remember that yeah yeah yeah yeah
he was like yo don't touch me but he
just got out so it was just it was just
it was it was a lot it was very it was a
very heavy situation
and uh we cleared it up a few months ago
and had an amazing conversation
but he's a unique individual for sure
ruthless
records were you a bone thugs and
harmony fan yeah of course easy for sure
easy bone thugs i got i got easy tattle
on my leg too but i got i ain't got no
shorts i got on these uh jogger pants
but i got a lot of people uh tearing on
my leg i mean you're paying homage um
if you had to give me your like top five
all-time rappers
pmc
juvenile
bumby
scarface
um what if we just combine ugk that's
one slot okay yeah we can do that then
what we're going to say so you're going
to jk ugk
juvenile
i mean juvenile um
scarface
uh
of course i gotta go easy easy even
though he didn't write his own rap yeah
so it's like cute
i i didn't say talking bigger because
everybody say packing big i appreciate
that yeah everybody say pocket everyone
says [ __ ] piggity jay-z
little wayne then you got to me too uh
boosting webbing
yeah
shout out to boozy hey um
boozy is also somebody who
i feel like
when they say don't meet your heroes or
don't meet celebrities because they'll
disappoint you
because they'll be [ __ ] or they
won't be who you think they are not the
case with boozy you hang out with boozy
and you're like he's even
more hilarious in real life this
motherfucker's hilarious
um yeah boozy and webby they gotta do i
heard them talking about doing um like
getting back together and doing
something
it's webby don't get enough love also
maybe a little crazy shout out to me
yeah webb
where every thugging though wherever
wherever for sure like
he don't get enough credit i don't i
don't think like outside the south he do
but that [ __ ] hard no webby's crazy
100
you don't have a like a jay-z or eminem
in there though
i'm not gonna lie like growing up i kind
of like was a big south head right i
could tell yeah
but i did love
listening to like bone though do or die
[ __ ] like that or die was crazy yeah
and they were on rap a lot yeah you
would die that pope pimping [ __ ] that
whole album yeah i i [ __ ] with them too
but i ain't gonna lie shout out to
chicago midwest [ __ ] we we we got down
what's real ugk
heads what's your favorite ugk album
come on now ryan dirty okay i gotta ask
you gotta know that i mean
you've gotta know that
murderer is like one of my favorite
i mean that's to me like quintessential
if you're gonna say bun b is one of the
goats you just press play on that come
on that's one of the best but i told him
that [ __ ] like a couple months ago i
forgot what song he thought
but i said i think he's got to be out of
murder one of your best verses ever
and on big paper that's one of your
questions
iconic but
is that what he said but that murder
record is
yeah i think i told him i think he was
saying like the uh the um what what did
you say big pimping oh no though but
that murder that [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] the king of moving chickens
oh they gotta be i don't see how that's
that's not one of the top albums in the
world like the uh it's to me it's
probably one of the i mean i i i that
one on the degree should be one of the
two of the top both classics for sure
you don't see you juvie don't get enough
challenges i mean don't get involved uh
i agree you know why i think cause his
his run
wasn't as long
as
we had maybe wanted it to be juve it
went for a long time because there was
400 degrees and then i feel like
the g-code which
was okay
but i feel like 400 degrees you know a
lot of people put out an album like 400
degrees and it's like
where do you go from here because it's
such a perfect body of work
i don't think he ever this man got one
of the biggest songs in the world
trending since what what 24 years now
back that ass up is one of the greatest
it's probably the single best club song
of all time of all time of all time no
matter where you are white party white
wedding jewish wedding black wedding
ratchet club bougie club you play back
that ass up is going up he don't get no
credit that man hard but he but he's
just melodic flow how he agree then
he'll
bounce into that uh reggae type tone
type [ __ ] like juvia's hard one of them
ones man judy's one of them i just think
that like if you think of like
i think that he unfortunately
i think his falling out with the cash
money [ __ ] probably had a lot to do with
his run being like a little stinted
as to where wayne was
he kind of took him beast
no for sure ain't a dog like that's
another [ __ ] like of course like i hate
to say them nigga's name because
everybody said but you got to give
credit when dude like you got to speak
when you talk to him you got to say
wayne you gotta say biggie you gotta say
pop you gotta say ho yeah you gotta say
hold too you know those are the ones
that are like yes it just they give you
that's why i don't like saying them so
much but now you would rather have a
listening to these like come on now now
they knew jay-z but it's that hundred
bars awesome cool on that
wayne's verse got overlooked on that
record wayne was talking that [ __ ] on
her lane cuz wayne is right he
influenced all this [ __ ] going on say
wayne wayne make a [ __ ] think
about two weeks what the [ __ ] he was
trying to say like what was he really
like getting it like here hey you like
what the [ __ ] was he saying it'd take
you that long to think about it what is
your favorite little wayne album uh
favorite lil wayne me personally i like
the carter one hmm
actually
to me it's carter one or two i like to
call them one
the first quarter that's that's [ __ ]
just that birdman junior birdman junior
birdman g i miss my dog miss my dog come
on man remember that what's up what's
going on
now what what's the other song that i
don't know what you say uh i'm gonna
bounce up my own click i'm my own [ __ ] i
will say [ __ ] you but go and get your
own dick
this this this is the caller ladies and
gentlemen do you remember um
do you remember the
when when uh the missed my dogs there
was like footage that back then went
viral however went viral was like
myspace or twitter or something of like
all of the hot boys i don't know if bg
was there i don't know if this is before
bg went to prison but little wayne
performed that song with juvenile and uh
and i i i i'm trying to think i ain't
seen it there was something so looking
up yeah it's online there was like a
point in time where at least juvie was
there when wayne did that record and
that wreck is so crazy if you think
about like then he said he missed his
dog as if they were dead but they not
dead he just said he just missing like
just them being around them
yeah this [ __ ] was around
juveniles since he was a child yeah
yeah carter once i respect that you know
what the one thing about wayne is that
i just feel like after
no ceilings which is in 09
i just never could really rock with any
of his projects after that was it i just
wasn't a fan of carter iv i didn't think
it was great there were some cool
singles
you're probably getting caught up in the
you gotta like if you're a die-hard fan
you're gonna be a die-hard fan of course
you're gonna be biased at the same time
but then again you know you like that i
am not a human being and the revolver
when he was doing the rock [ __ ] it just
was saying wayne being why he not
playing into the sound what's going on
right now carter five was like
two discs and
that was recently you know it was that
feels just
i hope the carter sixes
man he still laying i got one wayne just
going stupid he's still weighing he
still ain't he's still i just heard some
[ __ ] with him and change got going on uh
i'll tell you what probably my favorite
lil wayne project since no ceilings the
first no ceilings is probably the two
chains wayne project that [ __ ] was slept
on bro somehow i think they can have
something going on somehow when those
collab albums happen because most of the
time each artist is on their own label
they never get the the rightful push and
they always fly under the [ __ ] radar
like think about the wayne and two
chains [ __ ] there was some
hits on like that [ __ ] was crazy but
they were both i just feel like people
just probably don't because he ain't
been consistent in the sense of just
been dropping music so people
and then he went through the whole like
you know you try yeah he was trying to
get off he was trying to get i mean
there was that whole era of the free
weezy era you know what i'm saying so
but you're actually uh you had just told
me you were working with mag main now
who's helping you out so how did that
happen and shout out to mac main who's a
super nice guy really just just just
digging in the dirt not digging in there
just just digging around on some [ __ ]
like
he he we we keeping a relationship on
some mo [ __ ] and i'm telling like what's
going on with me
and [ __ ] like
bro i'm gonna help step in on some [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying so it's just
one of those situations where like the
relationship that's why i try to tell
people all day every day like
relationship is is it it gets you
farther than money relationships are the
biggest currencies there's more
important time in relationships yeah so
just me just me being me he bro brought
a couple players my way then i told him
like what situation going on you like
man i got you bro type [ __ ] you're gonna
get him out of missing a rap on
something for you
i don't know he said you know i heard
the [ __ ] rap yeah he said he uh
he said he said uh he was [ __ ] around
with this [ __ ]
we're talking about mac main right
uh-huh yeah make me rap i ain't no you
didn't i never heard them bro some of
these freestyles back in the day i never
heard the mixtape [ __ ] i never heard
them
yo this yeah yeah the squad up [ __ ] i
remember club sky in tampa i did an
after party with wayne and mac main was
there and i forget what but i played a
mac man freestyle
cause i was like yo if macmain comes i'm
just gonna drop this [ __ ] just right so
he'll be like the [ __ ] all right now i
heard he said he got something he said
he got some on that court too so we're
gonna see about this [ __ ] get him out of
retirement yeah
i will yeah you know low used to rap too
oh hello you what
so why don't you sign him he's been
riding with you this whole time
he's my manager man
he said i need to manage he
those are real lyricists wait i can't
say well lo is a real lyric still still
we about to find out when we throw this
beat on
you you got something
yo so you um you were
with hitco are you still with hit co
what is your label situation with asylum
so you're with asylum now shout out to
dallas who's over there
uh
everybody over there still yeah uh they
obviously gave you a great opportunity
you guys had a lot of success
um how many times platinum is that's on
me now i think three right [ __ ] that's
big man
not a lot of people can go gold for sure
the remix was amazing that was one of
those songs that like uh
yeah it was like it reminded me of like
you know like no matter where you were
in the country like you had you would
have to hear that record right like how
like designers panda was or like
jump man from just like yo yeah you
ain't got the yellow beezy in your [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] crazy for sure is it like
um a gift and a curse coming out
swinging with a hit like that because
you're always kind of chasing it i'm not
i'm never not chasing it it's just one
situation where you're like
[ __ ] i got other music in this
hit shoot right like you can go on my
camera i got actual hits yeah but that's
gonna be your biggest song they'll tell
you like some of this [ __ ] i get some of
your coming out song be your biggest
song like
i'm pretty sure me can't get away from
dreams of nightmares you know what i'm
saying regardless of what heathen came
without his accomplishment the first
thing that that's gonna be like come be
one on one no dreams and nightmares is
the one that's you know no matter where
he goes that's what's gonna get played
you know what i'm saying and you've had
other dope records with dope features
that did well at radio like you've had
other joints it's just a matter of like
wow like you said like that's your
biggest record i i definitely ain't
chasing none though
you would be trying to chase a uh that's
like a cat mountain we got to stop the
interview tell you about our partners at
odd socks well first of all let's check
out the brand new collab
look at these
the bootleg kev sock you see my pink ass
facing those [ __ ] socks nobody wants
to buy those we're gonna figure out a
way to give them away though uh but look
odd socks the most comfortable socks in
the world um and the best thing about
odd socks is they're our family man i've
been walking with these guys for about
10 years now and i will not wear
anything else on my feet like i swear to
god i'm about to take my shoe off i'm
going to take the look what is this
it smells great too that's an odd sock
right there that's an awesome basic you
know what i'm saying we [ __ ] with odd
socks you should too they got the crazy
licenses we're talking about nickelodeon
shout out to patrick [ __ ]
cheez-its
baywatch
how about macaroni underwear look at
these boys right here let's just crack
these [ __ ] open real quick what
do we got in here
come on man
yeah little pop-tart underwear yeah i
mean
yeah these are the odd socks basics all
right so if you go to the website right
now order you some underwear order you
some socks use the promo code bootleg
kev that's one word altogether bootleg
kev and you will save 20 off at checkout
go to
oddssoxofficial.com one more time that's
oddssodgeofficial.com promo code bootleg
kev and you will save 20 off your order
of course we're presented by odd socks
and we are proud to say so all right
let's get back to the interview like i
think it like little flip he was just up
here a couple weeks ago freestyling and
we were talking about um
you know he's obviously
put out so much music independently
but like [ __ ]
game over and sunshine well you know
that's kind of different though cuz well
he what i'm saying because he just had
tiger sample that record so it'd be like
yo
because i'd ask him i was like yo and
he's like bro it's 20 years later and
someone's sampling my [ __ ] like
it's a it's a forever bag yeah for sure
like if [ __ ] hits the fan you could
perform that song forever and and feed
your family yeah but they don't
understand it um so if this is the
mixtape
is there an album coming for sure what's
up with the album little wayne's on it
yeah most definitely you get a discount
on the verses for free
no you know why ain't [ __ ] with me so
it's free
nice were you in the studio when you did
it um i wouldn't but i one thing i can't
say that nigga's a solid [ __ ]
yeah just like just one of them people
like you know how like you say you look
up to people and coming up so you don't
know like how they are how they going he
kept it solid out like out the dribble
like was [ __ ] with me calling me like
hey like man him
just like kicking
and be texting on like some emotions
ain't got to be doing nothing with music
it can be about basketball cause we
gonna talk [ __ ] cuz he you know how he
feel about the match we're gonna talk
[ __ ] on
the uh the cowboys and he's a [ __ ]
green bay packers fan so you know we go
here is he attackers
he a real packers fan i mean i feel like
wayne b migrate wayne's like oh he been
like that no i know he's a hardcore
packers fan but i also feel like i'll
see him at like you know how snoop dogg
will just wear anyone's jersey like
shout out to snoop legend but like
snooperware anybody's jersey if he's a
friend with the player on the team like
snoop's a steelers fan everybody though
no no man i tell all my mommy i tell all
my nfl people
like
i'm my partner you better be my son
playing for the [ __ ] team
i'm a supporter i'll wear your jersey
for the show
only time i'm going against you when we
played when y'all played the show you're
wearing eagles jersey
i never said that
if your friends on the eagles i got a
homeboy there just lit jaylen my partner
j miller ringer jay mills was on the
eagle he played for the um we play new
england now that's one of my childhood
friends okay well what about if he plays
for the giants
that's listen man or the redskins listen
listen listen
listen like are you going to where i got
people that play for the judge you have
a so you have a good i ain't never done
it i'm saying i will though so you would
rock a giant strizzy as a cowboys woman
look are you trying to start some [ __ ]
because that's a that's a i mean that's
the nfc west or the nfc east rather than
that's a very um you know i haven't done
it okay but if i [ __ ] with you enough
i'll work jersey but at the same time
just like i told
who i told this [ __ ] the other day divo
samus yeah hey and me and him like wings
just like super duper cool though but
you know we [ __ ] with each other but
right i tell them i like only time i'm
going against you is dallas it's dallas
i tell everybody give a [ __ ] the niners
i'm not gonna say that i will
i'm a cardinals fan
it's tattered on my body so you know
where y'all quarterback's from then
right he's from [ __ ] of course come on
man you know every time he goes to
jerryland he lights that [ __ ] up like
we let you we let you all the [ __ ] up
oh we had him here two years ago i
didn't count when it was regular season
two years ago when there was the picture
of the fan like
we [ __ ] y'all up shout out to his dad
his daddy his daddy cussed us out his
daddy his daddy gonna talk [ __ ]
he cussed me out he cuss
they say that tyler they they say kyler
murray is the greatest football player
in texas history probably so yeah
you know him i mean he's like a tiny i i
you know what i don't know him
personally but i [ __ ] with his daddy you
know his dad his dad be doing coaching
with the little league players and all
type of [ __ ] is his dad
because i know he's biracial is his dad
black or his dad the asian side okay
okay that's usually how it goes right
yeah
[Laughter]
yeah he's black we're just being honest
ain't he a solid one but he gonna cut
your ass out when it comes when it comes
to his sons how do you feel about the
cowboys hello but like this year how we
feeling it's looking i mean look let's
be honest mike mccarthy is the only
thing y'all gotta get rid of because
he's a [ __ ] terrible head coach i'm
gonna just say this
we gonna be good
the line
now that i heard about by tyrone you
know and then you know i was
thinking about the receive record but i
know cd gonna do his thing for sure
city lam's a beast he's gonna he's gonna
i don't gonna play that part bro i just
i just we just need that [ __ ] i'm
already
cooper left right didn't he leave that's
my dog yeah he laughed down
damn
all for just sean to just go habitually
get tugs you know what i'm saying and
now he's got jacoby brissette for 14.
he's not going to play this year i think
he's i think like eight games no no they
pushed they made it more uh i think it's
11 or 12. for you yeah that's crazy
you ever hang out with deshawn watson in
h town
i ain't never met bro yeah you'd have to
be hanging out at a massage parlor to
meet him man
y'all don't know what that [ __ ] show you
gotta stop this this is my thing i think
what actually happened
was
he's probably just a normal dude who was
like paying masseuses
whether or not those masseuses were
actual masseuses or women who
you know how you go to get massages
should i'm not saying me but
[ __ ] begin massages they'd be
getting [ __ ] the happy ending at the
end i think that that lawyer they had
like a lawyer who found like one of
these chicks and then like put the word
out to everybody and then like now
there's just women coming out the
[ __ ] woodworks and it's a bag for
them it used to be some [ __ ] like
that and like you said bro like you said
back to your situation like you're not
saying that they're the same but like we
don't even know all the facts like he's
literally got nine figures on the line
for him it makes sense just to get it to
go away even if it's [ __ ] and he's
claiming his innocence that's a bigger
hustle in that lane versus mine for sure
for sure because you're dealing with
someone who's like a lot of people that
comment when i was even going through
that [ __ ]
what's athletes mm-hmm a couple of notes
rappers freestyle you know they'll go
through [ __ ] with a lot of athletes and
they said the same thing they they for
sure didn't do it but they were like man
just to get that [ __ ] on but i paid i
said bro i'm not doing that because even
more so than in hip hop if you're an
athlete your public image is so much
more of whether or not a team will even
sign you for sure
right it's like it don't matter if it's
that's what's crazy about like you said
the athlete [ __ ] i feel really bad for
those guys if they really didn't do
anything wrong it's a lot of them that
that's a lot of them that's a hustle bro
that's a broke [ __ ] hustle broke [ __ ]
hustle for sure she broke [ __ ] hustle
that's why when they try to
and like i say right now i can be one of
them people who kind of like blindside
about [ __ ] because my situation a
[ __ ] not seeing him in
particular but i'm gonna give a
[ __ ] the the the the benefit of
the doubt just because i know i've been
through that same situation and i know
how people can try to curl and keep on
coming with [ __ ] i'm talking about
just and they'll just keep on posting
the [ __ ] it'll make you look like
you just a [ __ ] animal bro so i know
what bro going through when it comes to
that [ __ ] and he probably literally
didn't do nothing i'm not saying he did
not we don't know
but but but based on his side he didn't
do nothing right so and
and i know
in my situation i do a [ __ ]
thing and they and they trying to dig
for it and they gonna make paint you to
be some that you ain't for sure are you
gonna um because i feel like
what i love
recently i don't know if you've noticed
cardi b's been suing blogs that have
been posting fake [ __ ] about her
and she sued some lady and got like a
suitor for three million dollars pretty
much bankrupted his blog for posting
but i feel like low-key the way to
combat that kind of behavior is to make
sure that those people who
accuse you of some [ __ ] or
[ __ ] about you like sue the [ __ ] out of
them they posted the [ __ ] i don't even
mean the blogs i mean like the lady who
who accuses you can't you sue her
you ain't got number glass water i want
that cup give me the cup of water yeah
yeah a couple water i want your new
balances i want your [ __ ] holy
[ __ ] what you you got a [ __ ] uh
you gotta wait ultima give me the oh
wait ultimate on this [ __ ] yeah
give me 75 percent of the only fans yeah
[ __ ] that [ __ ] they're bombing [ __ ] nah
man being them [ __ ] don't even get
[ __ ]
in trouble for the [ __ ] the
[ __ ] just get to go about their
lives and go try to do it to another
[ __ ] and john doe this [ __ ] in
another city you know what i'm saying
that's exactly what they be doing like
they need to make this [ __ ] to where if
these [ __ ] do that [ __ ] and they get
counting they lies them whole need to be
prosecuted
they
uh
watch out who you [ __ ] with and and and
be less trying to [ __ ] with your owlet
yeah i i i agree with all of you i feel
like if you falsely accuse somebody of
something
if you're if you find out that you were
being lied you need to be charged with
the same amount of jail time as if as
for the crime you're accusing that other
person stop a lot of this broke [ __ ]
hustle [ __ ] that they doing that'll stop
a lot of false allegations people want
to do this [ __ ] just get the money
they'll stop a lot of that [ __ ] make the
whole pay for their consequence that's a
yeah i agree man i agree 100
uh so your album coming soon
little wayne's on the album
right right okay anybody else i ain't
gonna tell y'all i slipped up and told
you that [ __ ] yeah well
i said man me and wayne got one yeah so
we know a little wayne's on the album
and now you and you're just gonna bring
mac man and him out of retirement over
there yeah for sure
you know uh
j.i.d just got the
president of dreamville to wrap on his
album oh for real ibrahim yeah shout out
to the homie
what are you doing
he's on a dream bill he uh just put out
in my opinion top three album of the
year jadi yeah jid jed he's from atlanta
okay y'all know i know who bro is no
he's fired yeah i know bro you gotta
listen to his album it's called the
forever um
i think
if i wanna i think his manager
or youtube i don't know who it was it
was dude his girl would used to be like
a pr for me
and that's how i um
that's how i got got up on him right
i forgot um
i think i forgot dude name i forgot his
name but the girl you said she used to
be do pr work for me and that's how i
got up on him
uh when yo when mo 3 was alive you guys
didn't get along much right or am i
wrong about that you're wrong i'm wrong
you guys did get along i mean never no
problem you never had no problems okay
because i okay i was gonna ask you like
mo three's passing
it feels like nationally
he finally got
the love that like he deserved when he
was alive but it took him dying for
people to come to his [ __ ] and really
like dive into his [ __ ] like how big of
a loss was moe three
uh to the city of dallas it was a big he
it was that was a big impact for him
like on the whole city like
in the end the [ __ ] like the song which
shout out to og baba biggest you know
that's real that's his song and [ __ ] but
he's from dallas as well of course of
course
and that's uh that's another [ __ ]
that's going crazy he's a super nice guy
yeah cool [ __ ] yeah so that more
fun that [ __ ] that's like that's one up
for them boys bro like real talk but it
made an impact in the city for sure yeah
do you feel like it kind of like it
sucks because i even feel like obviously
nipsey was was bigger than moe 3 when he
was alive but like i feel like the
impact of nipsey's music wasn't really
felt and or appreciated right it felt
similar it was like damn now
people
like are really [ __ ] with nipsey that
weren't even listening to his [ __ ] when
he was alive you know what i mean it
sucks that like sometimes you gotta see
somebody pass to really get the love and
respect that they deserve in this rap
[ __ ] sure that's how this [ __ ] go bro
yeah a lot of people don't get
appreciated to the past it just
it always got to be some type of
[ __ ] for a lot of people to get
their flowers though you know what i'm
saying sometimes so
just always just i guess it's part of
the game you've obviously had some like
uh close call situations when it comes
to just being back home or just getting
into issues
are you pretty conscious about
just moving like a different way now
that you kind of realize not only can
your life get lost but also you could
have some randomized [ __ ] try to take
your freedom away that [ __ ] can happen
anywhere but you still just got to move
more careful like you're going to get
more hate in your in your crib for sure
but like i say anything can happen like
that that [ __ ] can happen anywhere you
just gotta it ain't just where you move
how you move when you see just how you
move just period anywhere yeah just
everywhere because anything a [ __ ] can
act like she trying to um get a picture
with you and get a hug and try to say
you touched on it you know it's all type
of weird [ __ ] in this world you know
what i'm saying a [ __ ] can be just
trying to kill you just because they are
trying to ride because you got your girl
they don't feel like you got no straps
or something yeah it just feels like
when we see artists
you know for the most part recently you
know obviously dolph died in his
hometown nipsey died in his hometown
uh xxx santos young he got murdered in
his hometown i mean it just feels like
like i was saying earlier it just feels
like damn like it's like the people who
hate you the most are always where
you're from because they feel like they
should be where you're at a lot of [ __ ]
that is true for sure but a lot of [ __ ]
and this knows it'd be like more of the
smaller cities because like if a [ __ ]
from la you can still stay in l.a and be
off in the cut and be cool yeah where
are you from dallas dallas is huge
people don't understand dallas is fifth
part but we need to see him in the
country celebrities like that so we just
ain't got slavery like [ __ ] from new
york can live in new york be from new
york and stay in new york and can maybe
be in jersey
dallas is similar
yeah i had um there's a uh
twin peaks in plano texas
that uh
i had a good time with a young lady who
worked there back in the day
shout out to plano good good city i
don't know much about it outside of i
stayed in a hotel and there was a twin
peaks in the parking lot and
the talent is left [ __ ] so ain't
no telling it takes a big [ __ ]
it is huge yeah what is the drive from
texas to houston it's not too far like
three and a half four hours
what i meant to say texas to houston
jesus zero hours in that
yo west texas i always hear which is
obviously not where you're from but like
i'm sorry east texas rather like when
you get closer to louisiana when i drove
from phoenix to tampa
uh me and two of my boys
who were of color were with me and my
homies from texas were like whatever you
do
drive straight through east texas
because it's racist as [ __ ]
it's something i like in thailand [ __ ]
and lots of little smart small country
chances there's a city that starts with
a v that they specifically i think is uh
uvaldi texas does that sound right
yevaldi
no no you've always where that was yeah
i'm tripping no there's another city
there's a city uh where like they have
like [ __ ] billboards like white
supremacist billboards and [ __ ] in texas
what is it
maybe but yeah
oh no i don't know texas is just a wee
it's like it's like it's like a very so
big bro it's seated that i'm still
learning about this and i'm i've been
like later all my life like for real
like i just heard of another spot the
other day my homie them say he stay you
know his wife from and she said it and i
was like but i ain't never heard that
[ __ ] a day in my life you're like you
you do you like run the gauntlet though
you go to like corpus christi you go to
like mcallen get you some you know
like get the bag
i've in this
low they got the money i'm there what's
the most random place you've done a show
at random
csb chasers was gangster than a [ __ ]
shells be man seals be chased as [ __ ]
gangsta i ain't gonna lie [ __ ] on a
one-way street
one way the street but probably the size
of this table seem like
you can only go one way this [ __ ] was
packed i know like the building was so
[ __ ] it was it was it was big in the
inside but it was like real small though
it seemed like type [ __ ] but the street
was small as [ __ ]
long story short
we i'm performing on the stage with my
burner with my pistol in my hand and in
texas that's okay yeah but it's not
normal just for a [ __ ] just
performing
so many [ __ ] behind us with guns out
that was like just some gangster [ __ ]
like i swear to god like them [ __ ] is
gangsta i [ __ ] with this [ __ ] so you
performed holding your gun gun in my
hand my uncle nem and everybody else
behind me hit they straps out [ __ ]
behind who we didn't even know hit they
guns out so i'm knowing i ain't no
telling how many [ __ ] in front of us
got straps and [ __ ] then we get up at
them it took us about like an hour to
get up out there [ __ ] it was
just so small like everybody they just
where in texas is this it's like by
beaumont it's right beside beaumont
beaumont's near houston right right yeah
so
or something like that right
yeah yeah some [ __ ] like that so
yeah [ __ ] i think c has been
bulma getting to it they suppose got
some type of beef i guess so jesus i
don't know but i just know
we're using that [ __ ]
it took a long time to get out there
[ __ ] and we finally when we
literally hit the street
and made it right because we hit like
it was like in a neighborhood
residential area type [ __ ] they just had
a place [ __ ] were sitting outside on a
like the building yeah where they live
just sitting in like in the front yard
and everything just posted sitting on
their cars and everything so we see
[ __ ] i'm telling they got big old lad
choppers and [ __ ] like we looking at
these [ __ ] with this i'm like man what
the [ __ ] like what the [ __ ] is we doing
like
like these [ __ ] gangsta than a [ __ ]
as soon as we turn off the street
jesus that's crazy they start letting
that [ __ ] go not at us they had
some mobies going on but but at least
you got up out of there yeah
silvia was gangsta than a [ __ ]
have you met uh the white jordan yet
luca
look uh i tell me it looked like once or
twice how was that cool but i it wasn't
like no just know super duper like
i could really talk her we was at the
game type [ __ ] he's that [ __ ]
yeah that [ __ ] yeah y'all
[ __ ] [ __ ] my sons up bro yeah game
seven was the worst day of my life and
then we got my ball over there now whoo
well y'all got javel mcgee now on the
mavericks yes sir you know he makes
beats yeah he hear me that's what matter
of fact i got to kind of [ __ ] when i'm
out here because i think he had her but
he moved into that he hit him in the
other day so he's on the mavericks now
you guys got him
you also let jaylen brunson walk right
out that [ __ ] door that was true
why did they do that well he wasn't
consistent enough or something well he's
he's got family that's wrapped up in the
knicks organization that's why mark
cuban is going after uh there was like
tampering going on
pretty much mark cuban saying he they
never had a chance to keep him because
he'd already made his mind if he's going
to the knicks oh so basically that was
just his it's like his dad or his
brother some [ __ ] or both are like a
part of the knicks organization and oh
but yeah y'all have not had the greatest
offseason i'd expected y'all to like
land a name i mean javale's a great
there we got we got what's bro from uh
houston we got we we got somebody from
houston who uh the center right
senator from houston from the rockets
[ __ ] i don't know if there's
we got somebody right before him
right before mcgee
i don't know
what what's bro look look that [ __ ] up
hello i know this i know
that y'all need another [ __ ] score
at least tim hardaway yeah tim hardaway
i feel bad for luca luca reminds me you
know that meme remember during the uh
popeye's chicken craze there's that meme
of that lady sitting out of popeye's
just tired as [ __ ] i feel like i feel
like that's luca he's just carrying the
whole team you know what i'm saying but
y'all y'all beat us jason kidd is a
[ __ ] hell of a coach
great coach shout out to jay kidd man do
you have like season tickets to the the
mavericks of the uh cowboys christian
wood
yeah is that him christian wood okay
that's fair great pickup that's what we
got christian wood
center power forward yeah i forgot
christian wood yeah for sure i mean
he's hard no he's great but he heard but
he's not like a ball handler man we'll
get all this [ __ ]
who's the backup point guard who's the
[ __ ] shooting guard it's tim hardaway
jr who's else handling who else is
handling the power mark and i'm gonna
can you call mark cuban i really can't
want to see a taste mission yeah show me
that
tell that [ __ ] come on my show
[ __ ]
i met mark cuban when i was like and you
know what's crazy another person bro i
never think that i could even takes a
column and have conversations and he
literally if i was to shoot him a text
he'll lose like shoot back that's
amazing that's crazy right does he ever
give you any investment advice no i
ain't never asked somebody i know she
likes that's where you're [ __ ] up not
[ __ ] i haven't done it just be like hey
man i'm trying to see we be talking a
little bit on that [ __ ] hey yo
mark cuban got green bubbles boys green
bubbles he got that android
green bubbles mark cuban got that
android i i probably got the android
[ __ ] i don't know you have you have
three well you have two phones uh is are
they both iphones yeah okay so you don't
even [ __ ] with the androids
ever at life yeah but i i it i got a
iphone probably like 2 000
end of 2016 16.
yeah i was team android for so long and
two chainz ones uh and one of his songs
said uh trapping i'm live two chainz
said uh trapping on my android in like
2012 and i was like
yes yeah and then the next time i saw
him he had an iphone and i was like bro
what the [ __ ] i thought you were
trapping on your [ __ ] android bro
time's changing my brother i mean i got
an iphone now so there's that all right
so mixtape is out
music videos out
new album on the way
asylum records new situation for sure
um anything else going on
a lot of big big bags torn [ __ ] from the
goat jump off everything can jump off me
tv show i'm doing all this [ __ ] what
kind of tv are you doing like reality
doing acting or i'm gonna do something i
ain't doing a reality tv i don't want to
see you on the zeus network beating up
somebody yeah we ain't doing that
i feel like i'm gonna be in the sitcom
before i be in the goddamn um
reality tv shout out to goddamn i don't
i don't i don't even know what the zeus
network is or the 4s bias network i just
know
like hollywood unlocked and like all the
blogs
all they do is post clips from these
shows on these networks and their shows
look [ __ ] insane yeah it's like
krishan rock beating the [ __ ] out of
like seven girls at once with one two
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] crazy yeah oh shout
out to kashan rock her and blueface got
serious oh that's what it is yeah yeah
yeah that's all girl yeah serious
romance
have you ever had a romance like that
that was like you knew it wasn't good
for you but you just fought through it
anyway
i mean i think we out and done that of
course that's the most toxic [ __ ] most
toxic [ __ ]
i had to tear i mean my son's mom was
just a just god-awful human being i got
trackers on my calls oh wow well you
know now with those new apple tags
that's actually not hard to pull off
just throw that [ __ ] in the back seat
yeah you have to be careful out here
toxic as [ __ ] toxic hey baby there it is
go run up his [ __ ] yeah appreciate you
oh cliff in the [ __ ] building